انظر إلى هؤلاء المحللين الذين يعتقدون أن هذه الصواريخ تم
إطلاقها في مكان ما هنا على طول هذه
الحدود مع الكويت والعراق وحلقت فوق
الكويت ثم نزولًا لضرب هذه
المنشآت النفطية هنا وهم يعلمون أن
إيران لديها أحد أقوى برامج الصواريخ
في المنطقة بأكملها بما في ذلك
بعض البرامج البعيدة.  مدى صواريخ كروز أحد
الأمثلة ، يوجد هذا التصميم القائم على
صواريخ كروز السوفيتية التي
يبلغ طولها حوالي 24 قدمًا ، ويمكن إطلاقها من
منصة إطلاق متحركة مثل الشاحنة ،
وبينما تتحرك بسرعة دون سرعة الصوت مثل جميع
صواريخ كروز ، فإنها تعانق
رادار التهرب من الأرض لمئات الأميال
وهذا يمكن أن ينتج عنه هذا النوع
من الضرر تمامًا ، لكن التمسك بالمتمردين الحوثيين
في اليمن يقولون إنهم مسؤولون عن سبب
تركيز هؤلاء المحللين على
الإيرانيين لهذا بدلاً من الحوثيين
عدة أسباب لأن هذه أكبر
منشأة لمعالجة النفط في العالم ، حيث
كان هناك 17 فردًا.  الضربات هنا تظهر
وفقًا لهؤلاء المحللين الذين
أتوا من الشمال ، هذا
اتجاه إيران ليس جيئة وذهاباً  م الجنوب الذي هو
اتجاه اليمن والحوثيين كما
أنهم كانوا نظرة دقيقة للغاية على هذه
التفاصيل على هذه الدبابات الأربع
المتماثلة تقريبًا على كل واحدة في نفس
المكان والتي تتحدث إلى درجة من
التعقيد التي يتمتع بها الإيرانيون
تمامًا الحوثيون  ليس كثيرًا
وكان من المعروف أن الإيرانيين يضربون
أهدافًا نفطية مرة أخرى ، فهذا ليس
نمطًا أظهره الحوثيون كثيرًا من
الانجذاب لذلك يمكنك أن ترى بينما بدأت الأدلة
تشير أكثر وأكثر
نحو الإيرانيين وبصراحة قد ترى
النتائج أكثر قليلاً - في الوقت الحالي
، يبلغ متوسط تكلفة جالون الغاز في
لولايات المتحدة 256 جالونًا ، يع
قد بعض الخبراء أن انقطاع إم
ادات النفط العالمية بسبب هذه ال
جمات قد يؤدي إلى زيادة ذلك بنحو 25٪ في
لولايات المتحدة.  الأسابيع القليلة القادمة ومن يدري كم من
الوقت سيبقى هناك